PROFESSOR: Today,
we continue-- we're
going to do two things today.
One is protein folding and the
other is interlocked chains.
So protein folding,
we're continuing
on where we left off last
time, which was essentially
looking at the mechanics, the
mechanical models of protein
folding, which was
fixed angle chains.
But basically ignoring
all the forces that
go into actual protein folding.
Today, we're going
to look at some
of the very theoretical
work on what
forces cause proteins
to fold and what
you can say about algorithms and
complexities of those problems.
So obviously, a lot of people
work on protein folding.
On the practical side,
people look a lot
at defining energy functions
that you minimize in order
to find what we believe would
be the right protein folding.
There's a lot of energy
functions around,
and the key energies that--
forces people look at
are torsion angles potentials,
van der Waal interactions,
hydrogen bonds, hydrophobicity,
secondary structure propensity,
and paralyze specific
interactions.
And then they take some weighted
combination of all those things
and try to find
one that matches up
with what we see in real life.
The things we see
in real life, we
get by crystallizing
proteins, which
can take a really long time,
like years of research.
Then you get one 3D image.
And that's what protein data
bank collects is all those 3D
images.
People try to train against
that data, but I say,
we really don't know
what the right objective
is for real protein folding.
Given that, because
I'm a theoretician,
we're going to look at
a super simple model
that just models one of those
features that I mentioned,
which is hydrophobicity.
Hydrophobia is fear of water.
And remember we have
this back on the protein,
the various amino acids hanging
off, some of those amino acids
are hydrophobic, meaning
they like to hide from water.
Now usually, your proteins live
in a big bath of fluid, mostly
water, and so they're trying
to hide from the surroundings,
try to cluster on the
inside of the folded shape,
whereas other hydrophilic amino
acids that like water, they
tend to go around the outside.
You can't always
do this, but you
try to minimize the amount to
which the hydrophobic guys are
on the outside and maximize
the hydrophilic guys are
on the outside.
In the HP model, there are
hydrophobic and hydrophilic
guys.
And actually, we'll
call h the hydrophobic
and P the hydrophilic.
It's very confusing
because both of them
have h and p in the acronym,
but p also apparently stands
for polar, polar opposite
of the hydrophobic guys.
Anyway, we just have
these two kinds of nodes,
and we just try
to model that one
feature, plus the bonds
that link together,
the backbone of the chain.
And so we're going
to model a chain
as just a sequence of nodes.
We're going to fold
that chain on a lattice.
Something like this.
Is it five?
Yeah.
And different of these nodes
could be marked h or p.
And we usually could use
two colors to denote that.
In this case, I made this guy
h, this guy h, this guy h.
The score of a fold--
so this is a folding.
We're always going to
fold on the square lattice
today although people have
looked at other lattices,
in particular 3D cubic
lattice and a little bit
on the triangular lattice.
I'll mention some reasons
why the square lattice is
a little bit artificial,
but in general, conjectures,
it doesn't really matter
which lattice you fold on.
But you really want
to follow lattices
because we're going to
define the score in terms
of how many adjacent H nodes
there are on the lattice.
Score is the number of
call them H-H bonds.
The intuition is if you have
two hydrophobic nodes that
are next to each other
that means they're not
next to the boundary,
and so they're happier.
There's a more formal
argument of that,
but this is an easy
definition of score.
You want to maximize
the number of H-H nodes
that are adjacent
on the lattice.
Usually, there are some that
are adjacent along the chain.
Those we don't care about
because they will always
be adjacent.
You have to fold this thing
so that consecutive nodes
in the chain appear
adjacent in the lattice.
So we usually ignore what I
would call H-H edges which
are four, so you can
count them or not.
It doesn't really matter.
We want to maximize the
number of these guys.
For this chain, that's probably
the maximum you can get.
In general, a typical node
has two edge neighbors,
and it has two other neighbors.
And so at most, every
guy has-- every H node
has two bonds next
to it, which means
on average at most
one bond per H node
because we're double counting.
So that's the model.
The optimal folding
has the maximum score.
And I'm going to
talk about the theory
of this model in a moment.
Some practice you might
say is this picture.
This is heuristic or local
optimization of maximizing.
Here, red nodes are H nodes that
will be throughout the slides.
Red nodes are H nodes.
Blue nodes are P nodes.
That's a universal standard.
You can see, in this
case conveniently--
it may look like some random
pattern of reds and blues,
but you end up with all the
blues pretty much covering
the outside, and so the
reds cluster together,
and there's lots of H-H bonds.
They are not drawn here,
but-- So that's nice.
And this looks like
a typical protein
in that it globs together.
But of course, it's not
capturing every feature
of protein folding, just
trying to capture one of them.
But pretending this
is the whole story,
what can you say about optimal
folding in the HP model?
Well sadly, it's NP-hard.
So to find the actual
optimal folding of a given
string of red and
blue nodes is NP-hard.
It's NP-hard in the
3D cubic lattice.
That was by two MIT professors,
Bonnie Berger and Tom Leighton
And then it was proved
NP-hard hard in two dimensions
by whole bunch of people,
I guess, from Berkeley.
So that's bad news.
And to me, that's a sign
that nature probably
does not find the
optimal folding.
There are a couple
possibilities here.
Maybe they're extra forces
beyond hydrophobicity
that make it easier to
find the optimal solution
or maybe nature's just
finding a local optimum, not
a global optimum.
Or maybe the proteins that
exist in real life that
have been evolved are designed
so that local optima equal
global optima.
That's somewhat related.
Somehow nature gets around this
NP-hardness, I would think,
because I believe
nature's a computer.
Maybe not everyone does.
But it should be bounded by
polynomial time computation.
So unless P equals NP-- that's
another possibility I guess.
It's unlikely that, to
me, nature is doing this.
But maybe it's
finding local optimum.
That seems to do pretty well
in this particular example.
AUDIENCE: Hey Erik?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.?
AUDIENCE: Are there
approximation algorithms?
PROFESSOR: Good question.
Are there approximation
algorithms,
that's exactly where
I wanted to go.
There are lots of constant
factor approximations,
and I will show you one of them.
So I'm not going to show
you these hardness proofs
because they're a
bit complicated.
I don't have free
diagrams of them.
But the constant factor
approximations, I do.
Where are we going?
Here.
And so, in particular, the
best approximation that's known
is a 1/3 approximation.
This is by MIT Ph.D.
student [INAUDIBLE],
and from several years
ago-- eight years ago.
I believe it's still the best.
It's pretty simple,
but quite elegant,
looks like protein folding.
So this is going to be
within a factor of three
of the best you could hope for.
We write 1/3 because we're
always getting fewer bonds
than you might want in
a maximization problem.
Some people call this
three approximation.
I call it one of the other
depending on the day the week.
So how could we achieve
1/3 approximation?
Well, before I get to this
image, let me tell you.
In general, when-- we
haven't talked too much
about approximation
algorithms in this class,
but a typical technique in
approximation algorithms is you
get some bound on what
the optimal might be.
I already told you there's at
most one bond for each H node.
And that is indeed-- that's
roughly what we'll say.
Just because of the
degree argument,
every guy has bond
degree at most two.
So that means, at most,
one edge per H node.
But we can be a little more
precise on the square grid
because there are
two types of nodes.
If you checkerboard
color the square grid,
there's even nodes
and odd nodes.
So in fact, we claim that
the optimal solution,
which we call OPT, is
always at most twice the min
of the number of even H's
and the number of odd H's.
This is slightly smaller
than the number of H's.
If a number of H's
and not H's are equal,
then this will just
be the number of H's.
But if one is smaller
than the other,
this will be a
little bit smaller
or it could be a lot smaller.
They're saying, no even H's.
The point is if you
have an even parity H,
and it somehow has a
bond with some other H,
well obviously, that h has
different parity from this one.
So only even and odd H's
could possibly bond together.
And then this is pretty obvious.
Let's see if I can formalize it.
So you have every bond
defines and even and an odd.
Every even and odd can
only get hit up to twice.
If there's more evens and odds,
it's not going to help you.
In the best case, you pair
them up or alternate even odd,
even odd, even odd.
So you'll never be able to
use more evens than odds,
maybe one more, not really.
And I think the best case is
you do a cycle of even odd,
even odd, even odd.
Then, there's an even
number of them-- each,
an equal number of each.
And so you throw
away the excess.
You end up with
a min of the two.
But you get a factor of two
because every even guy has
two incident bonds
in the best case,
and then you're
not double counting
because you count this even guy,
maybe you count this even guy,
and they have disjoint bonds.
So it's twice the number
of evens or number
of odds, whichever is smaller.
So this is useful.
It's just what is the best
case you could hope for OPT?
Now, what this 1/3
approximation will get
is at least 1/3 this amount.
If you know you get at
least 1/3 this amount,
you know you get at
least 1/3 the optimal
because this is an upper
bound on the optimal.
So that's with the
algorithm will do.
And so the general
idea of the algorithm
is to proceed in stages.
At a typical stage--
So you pick some edge.
I don't think it'll
matter too much.
Pick some edge of the
chain, and then you
start working your way down.
And general idea is you can
make big loops off to the sides
so that when you get back to
the center, these are H nodes.
So you get a bond there.
That's the general idea.
With that basic idea, you
probably get about 1/4
of this amount.
But we want to get 1/3,
which is a little better.
I won't try to
analyze that formally.
But there's a lot
of flexibility here
when we-- how long
we make this branch.
In order to make
this work out, what
I like is that the left branch
has a lot of-- pick one-- a lot
of even H's, and the right
branch has a lot of odd H's,
or vice versa
because then we'll be
able to make lots
of the even guys
match up with the odd guys.
Here, we're fighting the parity.
And parity is one
of the reasons why
I think the square grid is
a little bit artificial.
Let's say with the triangular
grid, you wouldn't have that.
There aren't just two classes.
But here, we can
get around parity
by finding a break
point, this edge,
so that the number of
even guys in the left
is about the number of
odd guys on the right.
I won't prove that, but it's
just an intermediate value
argument.
See, you get that as you
walk counterclockwise
along the chain, you
have more even guys,
and walk clockwise around the
chain, you get more odd guys.
Once you have that set up,
you fall into four cases.
So we're supposing at the
top-- let me get to a case,
that I can reach.
Here's a typical case.
Suppose you just
succeeded in making
two H nodes join together.
Maybe that was your
first edge, whatever.
So it might not be H-H. But
now, we're proceeding down,
and we want to align
a bunch of H nodes.
And we're going to do better
than the picture I drew over
here, which was just getting
two H nodes to come together.
I actually want to
get four H nodes
to come together
with three bonds.
That's what I will always
achieve, at least that.
Is that right?
Actually, no, this
is the good case.
I won't always achieve quite
that well, quite that good.
But here's the idea.
Suppose there's some reasonably
large distance between this H
node and the next one.
I'm going to go down two steps
and then go around however
long it takes so that when I
come back, I get to an H node,
and same on the left side.
So these two chains may
have different lengths
depending on when
the next H node is.
Now, when I say the
next H node, I actually
mean the next odd
H node on this side
and the next even H node on this
side so that they will line up.
This is assuming that
the distance from this H
node to the next one
is greater than 1,
by parity that means
it's at least three.
So if it's three, it's
going to be one, two, three.
And that's it.
And so go straight down.
If it's more than
three, you just
divide that distance in half,
and you go back and forth.
And this sets the parity right.
So that's the set up.
Now, we have these two H nodes.
Now, when are the next H nodes?
Well, there's at
least one blue node
in between because of parity
because we're looking again
at odd H nodes on
the right side,
even H nodes on the left side.
So maybe it's just
one blue node,
and we would go like this, and
here we would go like that.
Or if it's more
than one blue node,
we just lay them out like this.
Goes to the
appropriate distance,
so that when we come
back, we get a red.
So we have two red H nodes here.
I want to make two red H
nodes here no matter what.
If it's just gap of one,
we would go straight, make
a corner, otherwise,
we do these big loops.
And the result is I
get these four H nodes
in this pattern, just three
bonds for four H nodes.
And before we analyze
what exactly that means,
let me just tell you
about the other cases.
So this is the case when there
is more than one blue node
in between two H nodes.
The other rows and
columns are when
the left side or
the right side has
just one blue node
from that red guy.
So let's go to this
one for example.
Here the left side has only one
blue node to the next red guy.
The right side has
at least three.
So then we'd go one, two,
three, and we get there.
If it's a more than
three, then we go
and we make that big loop.
Now we have these
two read nodes.
My goal now is to
put a red node here.
If this chain only has one blue
node, I would make a corner.
Otherwise, I'd loop around, and
then I go onto the next step.
Here, I only got two
bonds for three nodes,
so it's actually a
little worse in ratio.
In the case where
they're both length one,
I just go straight down,
make those two H nodes,
and then I use the
same trick as over here
to get that nice
zig-zag pattern.
And this case is symmetric
to this one, just flipped.
So in all cases, I
didn't skip anything.
I did all of the even H
nodes on the right side.
I did all of the odd nodes,
H nodes, on the left side.
So I did skip something.
I skipped all of the odd
guys on the left side
and all the even guys
on the right side.
So I skipped half
of the H nodes.
So I get at least two
bonds-- I'm calling them
H-H bonds-- for every
three interesting H nodes.
By interesting, I just
mean even on the left,
odd on the right, which is
really for every six H nodes.
And so we get a factor of
2/6, also known as 1/3.
Really here I mean
6 even H nodes.
Let's say.
We used the same number
of even and odds.
And we had-- Is that right?
Sorry.
No, I guess I actually
made H nodes here.
I always get a little
confused here because there's
a factor of two, a
factor of two here.
But in the end we get 1/3 bound.
So that's the
approximation algorithm,
and that's the best node.
It looks pretty nice.
It's like beta sheets, if
you've seen proteins folding.
it depends, of course, on
the spacing of the H nodes,
but you get-- in particular,
you get all the H nodes
on the inside pretty much.
I guess here is one exposed end.
And here there's
one exposed end.
These two cases, we're
doing especially well.
Maybe in real proteins, the
gaps are always more than one.
I don't actually know.
I think in reality
there's different levels
of hydrophobicity, so that's
maybe not so well defined.
But any questions?
AUDIENCE: Is the exposed end
considered the [INAUDIBLE]
above the dashed line or is it--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
When I say exposed
end, I mean here.
There's an adjacency
to the outside water.
Now of course, there might
actually be nodes here.
Then, that would not
be an exposed end.
But if this just
went straight up,
which it might in this
picture, then that
would be an exposed end.
I guess that might also be.
No, probably not.
Actually, interesting.
If these two guys
are red, there's
always a blue node to the
left and right of them
in this construction,
so actually, I
think that would not be exposed.
That's cool.
So actually, I think
there are no exposed
ends in this folding,
except maybe at the very top
and bottom.
Except, we're only considering
half of the H nodes,
so there's the other half
we have no idea about.
So hopefully, nature
chose the parity right.
Or, if you think about this is
in the triangular case, which
I don't think anyone's
tried to adapt
this algorithm to
the triangular grid,
maybe you can get
no exposed node.
So that would be pretty neat.
Of course reality, it probably
does not fold on a lattice,
but it's an approximation.
Now, one of the observed
features in protein folding
is they tend to fold
to the same shape.
It's actually a hard
thing to measure,
but that's the
general consensus,
that at least most proteins
in a non diseased organism
fold always to the
same shape, at least
in the same environment.
So if you want to model
that in the HP model,
and you pretend that, really, we
are finding optimal solutions--
because it's a
little hard to define
what locally optimal means.
But that would be an
interesting direction.
It would be nice
to find proteins
where locally optimal
equals globally optimal,
but lacking definitions
of those terms,
no one has tried to prove that.
It could pick a good direction.
But if you believe in
optimality, then at least
you hope that the
optimal are unique.
So you take a typical
example of the optimal,
like if they're all blue,
then every folding is optimal.
So there's exponentially
many of them.
But if you have any hope
of getting unique folding,
you'd really like
unique optimal foldings.
The theorem is these exist.
And the 2D squared
grid, they exist
for all even n, for
closed chains-- mostly,
we care about open chains,
but for closed chains,
you could prove these
exist for all even n--
and for open chains, they
exist for all doubly even n.
This is a theorem by
a bunch of people.
Oswin Aicholzer, David
Bremner, me, Hank Meijer,
Vera Sacristan,
and Michael Soss,
we talked about last time.
So here they are
for closed chains.
It's a pretty simple example,
basically alternating red blue,
but at the end, you have two
blue nodes to make the corner.
That is not the optimal folding.
The optimal folding is this.
So there's only
two exposed ends.
There's one down here,
and one on the top.
So there's no surprises that
it's optimal, a little less
obvious that it's
uniquely optimal.
But there it is.
And this works for any even n.
In general, it depends a little
bit on your the n mod four, so
that's why we are drawing
two pictures here,
to check that it works for
both congruences mod four.
It has to be even
for closed chain
and must be even, so
this is really for all m
that there's closed
chains, there
are unique-- there are
examples of HP chains
that have unique
optimal foldings.
Here, it's just to do you end
going horizontal or n going
vertical?
Not a big difference.
I have a proof by picture that
this is the optimal folding.
So remember there
are two-- we talk
about H-H edges and H-H bonds.
These are what we
call P-P edges.
And I remember when writing this
paper, one of the co-authors,
I won't say which one,
saying call me juvenile,
but I don't want to have a paper
that talks about P-P edges.
And I convinced him to keep it.
So we have-- it's
really only obvious
when you say it out loud,
which sadly I have to do here.
But you have two of those
edges, all blue edges,
we might also call them.
And they really should
be on the boundary
because you have to have
exposed ends on the boundary,
on the bounding
box is what I mean.
So if you put too many red
guys on the bounding box,
you're going to
lose lots of bonds.
So those two blue guys
should be on the boundary.
Some two edges have
to be on the boundary,
so it's best to have
the two blue ones.
So we could show you in optimal
solutions, that is the case.
Now, you decompose
into two chains
that connect the two ends.
There's connecting
this end to the left
and connecting this end up and
around to the other blue node
at the end.
And if you check all of
the red notes on this side
have even parity, let's say,
and all the red nodes on this
die have odd parity
because it alternates.
So there's no way
that you could have
bonds within one
of those chains.
That's not drawn here.
The other thing is because
these two blue edges are
on the boundary, you cannot
have a bond on the outside
because there's
no hope for that.
You can only have bonds on the
inside of that closed loop.
Here, we're using that
it's a closed loop.
So you have bonds on the inside,
and then you argue, well,
because it's bipartite graph
and because it's planar,
you can't have any
crossings in these bonds
because you're embedding
this thing in the plane,
really you basically
have to alternate.
There's actually two ways
you could try to alternate.
You start on this side or
if you start on this side.
You try to realize
them geometrically.
When you do this alternation,
you decompose your thing
into squares.
Only in one case does it work,
and you get this picture.
And then once you
have the squares,
there's a unique way
to glue them together.
So that's how the proof goes.
It's pretty easy once you
get the right limits in place
for closed chains.
Let me show you what
happens for open chains.
Take the same example for open
chains, and it's almost unique.
In the double even case,
like 16, it is unique.
In the only singlely even,
so two mod four case,
like 18, you have this issue.
So the way we set
up is we do not
have the blue blue at
the end to turn around.
That is the best
we know how to do.
And there are
these two-foldings,
how you might achieve it.
So here, we wrap around and get
a little triad of blues here.
Because we have
a red n point, we
can actually get
three bonds into it.
Or, we can do the
intended folding.
Now, it's a pretty small change,
so it's approximately unique,
but that's the best we know for
open chains, only singly even
length.
Or for odd length, we also don't
know anything that's optimal.
Of course there are things
that are almost optimal.
You just add a little end.
Won't make a big difference,
but interesting open problem.
Also open, whether any
of these unique results--
uniqueness results
extend to other grids,
like triangular grid.
That would be nice because here
we're really exploiting parity,
and that's kind of cheating.
Certainly, parity is not
such a big deal in real life,
but I don't know.
Could be.
The approximation algorithm's
generalized to other grids,
not necessarily this one,
but some constant factor
approximation have
been obtained.
Uniqueness is open.
The really cool open
question here, I think,
is protein design.
HP model is simple enough
we can think about it.
And while folding-- finding
the optimal folding of a given
protein is NP-hard, if I
get to design the protein,
and say, well, I'd really like
to fold into-- I don't know.
The letter m-- how do I make a
protein fold into the letter m,
at least approximately?
So ideally, it should still
have a unique optimal folding,
so we generalize
this result, but it
can match any target shape.
Here, we're matching
a diagonal line
up to some constant
factor resolution.
Can we match any shape up
to some constant factor
resolution?
I think the answer
should be yes.
And then you should be able
to solve that polynomial time.
In the same way that origami
design is a lot easier
than origami
foldability, here, I
think protein design
should be a lot easier
than protein folding.
But no one has worked on that.
I think it's a
really cool problem.
To bad I'm mentioning it
so late in the semester,
but we can work on it
in the problem session.
So ends my coverage
of protein folding.
Obviously, there's tons
of work I'm not covering,
but I'm focusing on the
very algorithmic stuff.
Any questions before we go?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: In these models
you have, are these
supposed to equal
number of P and H,
can you get in situations
where you're way
overbeared with P
or H, and then it's
going to be harder to
find an optimal folding.
Or, is it not
realistic because these
are such-- these are small
sets of the entire protein?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So the question
is whether-- Does
it matter the ratio between the
number of H nodes and P nodes.
I think the easy-- A sure
thing is I don't know.
My guess is, in
reality, the number of H
and P's are within a constant
factor of each other,
for some constant.
I don't think the
constant matters too much.
Although if there's an
overwhelming majority
of H's or P's, the problem
might become easier.
My guess also is in
the NP-hardness proof
although it's been a
while since I read it.
There's probably a
constant factor again.
But maybe you could show
if there's-- for example,
if there's a constant
number of h nodes,
I'll bet you can solve
it in polynomial time.
That's maybe-- That's
a new open problem.
I should write it down.
Good question.
AUDIENCE: If there is a
wrong factor between them,
wouldn't we see
that at the model
because it just wouldn't work?
PROFESSOR: No, this model makes
sense for any number of reds
and H's and P's, but uniqueness
is probably hard to obtain
if you have a small number
of H's or if you have a huge
number of H's.
If you don't have enough--
AUDIENCE: What if you have
H's on the order of the square
of the P's, then there
are at least two H's?
PROFESSOR: All right.
AUDIENCE: Kind of
makes sense, right?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
actually we have
a theorem along those lines,
which is not published
so that's why I'm
not talking about it.
You can achieve the number
of H's as square the number
of P's.
I imagine that's the limit--
and still get uniqueness.
I imagine that's the limit.
We really ought to
write that result
that it's from seven years
ago, so unlikely at this point.
Other questions?
So we go onto
interlocked 3D chains,
which is related in that
it's in 3D and its chains.
So related to the
mechanical protein folding
we did last class,
except here, mostly,
I'm going to think about
universal joints again,
so I can do whatever I want.
I don't have to hold
the angles fixed.
At the end, I'll
mention how things
change a little bit for when
you have fixed angle chains.
But universals more fun.
So the motivation
here is we have
our good friend the
knitting needles example,
or maybe our mortal
enemy, depending
on how you like
to think of that.
One, two, three, four, five.
And remember-- never
mind the edge lengths.
I'm not going to worry
about edge links here.
With five bars, you
can lock the chain.
So an interesting
question is what
if I had less than five
chains, say length 4 chains,
but I had more than one of them.
Now certainly, each
chain will be unlocked.
That's a known result by
Cantrell and Johnson '96.
'96, '98?
'96.
But what if I have two four
chains, can they interlock?
The answer turns out to be yes.
The original motivation
for this proble,--
it's a neat question by itself,
but the original motivation is
something called
Lubiw's problem.
Many of you met Anna Lubiw,
she's one of my Ph.D. Advisors.
Last year, she was
here on sabbatical.
And the question
is the following--
so she posed this back
in 2000, a long time ago.
What is the minimum
number of cuts
you have to make in a 3D
chain in order to unlock it?
I say unlocked meaning we
know they are locked chains.
Suppose I want to make the
configuration space connected,
but I allow cheating and
I allow cutting vertices.
How many do I have to cut?
And say the chain has n bars.
Then, as a function of n,
how many cuts do I need?
And the answer at this
point, in the worst case,
we know is between about
n over 2 and n over 4.
So it's at least 4
over n minus 1 over 4.
And it's at most 4
n minus 3 over 2.
And I'll prove to you
both of those results.
So we know roughly its theta n.
It's in a constant
factor of n, but we
don't know exactly
what the constant is,
still a neat problem.
Originally this motivation
here is, well, maybe-- there's
some theories that
in real proteins,
maybe they disconnect their
bonds for a little while
so they can pass through
and make things cross.
How many disconnections
would you
need because that might
require a lot of energy?
The answer is a lot if
you have a long protein.
in the worst case of course.
Real proteins have unit edge
lengths almost equal angles,
so maybe the answers
change in that case,
but given that we don't
even know whether it's
a locked chain, in
those situations,
it's pretty hard
for us to answer
something more
complicated like this.
So let me start with
the lower bound.
You need to make at least
n over 4 cuts almost.
Any ideas how to do that
before I show you the answer?
Given the one tool we have,
which is the knitting needles.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I mean
if you [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Just
connect a whole bunch
of knitting needles together.
Yeah.
Now, knitting needles
has five edges,
so that would naturally
give n over 5.
But if you're a little bit
clever, you can share edges.
If you share the long edges
from one knitting needle
to the next, and you get about
4 bars per knitting needle,
except the very first bar which
have to count extra, and so
that's the n minus
1 divided by 4.
Now if you don't cut
one of the vertices--
and here, we're
considering vertex cuts--
if you don't cut
one of those four
vertices of that
knitting needle,
the whole thing will be
locked because that's
a knitting needle.
So you have to cut one of those
four, and one of those four,
and one of those four just for
the pieces to not be locked.
The trouble is-- so the natural
algorithm, if I give you
some big complicated chain,
is cut every fourth vertex.
That we know does not work.
I think I have to
wait to see that one.
Let me tell you what's
known about interlocking,
and then we'll get back
to Lubiw's problem.
But at least we've
proved this part.
And next thing I want to
do is prove this part.
And to show you how
we might do that, I
think I need a whole board.
We're going to think about
an open chain of length 2--
let me make a little
more room-- 2,
3, 4 interlocking with-- start
with an open chain of length 2,
3, or 4.
There's going to be other
results, but it's a good start.
So for 2, 2 chains, I
claim are always separable.
And I'm going to put
a little asterisk
to mean another thing is true.
A 2 chain and a 3 chain
is always separable.
A 2 chain and a 4 chain
This matrix is symmetric.
A 3 chain versus a 3
chain also is separable.
But everything else,
you can interlock.
I guess I haven't
defined interlock.
Be a good idea.
I call a bunch of-- a
collection of chains
separable if they can all fly to
infinity away from each other.
So the distances
between them can
get arbitrarily large,
otherwise they're interlocked.
And usually, that will
mean that no pair of them
can fly away from each other.
Here, we're just
thinking about two
at once, so it's either
separable or interlocked.
So this is a worry
if you're thinking
about cutting this apart.
You cut every fourth
bar-- fourth vertex,
if I get the counting
right, I think
that means you have length
4 chains connecting them.
Now, we know length 4
chains can't be locked,
but they could be interlocked.
And so you could
actually build an example
where if you do the simple
pattern of every fourth cut,
you will get interlocking.
It's still open whether you
could be clever and still
only make about n over 4
cuts and get everything
to separate, but to solve
that, you'd have to get around
this boundary, this annoying
situation, which we don't fully
have characterized.
We just have examples.
And we also thought
about-- and we'll
get to this later--
if you try interlock
an open chain with
a closed chain.
With two closed
chains, it's trivial.
You can just make a
knot, or make a link.
I guess is the proper term.
But an open versus a closed is
more interesting, especially
if that closed guy
is not itself a knot.
I think up to length 5.
Yeah, I think the
smallest, locked,
closed chain is of length 6.
Never showed it to you,
but that is a known fact.
So up to 5, we know this
thing is not by itself locked,
so it's not really cheating
compared to an open chain.
Then, the answer is separable,
separable, separable.
It's really hard to lock
things with a 2 chain.
2 chains, we call hairpins.
That's a 2 chain.
Everything else is interlocked.
Basically, the same results
hold whether one of your chains
is opened or closed because
notice there's a shift here.
The smallest closed
chains have length 3,
and the smallest open chain
is really of length 2.
I guess you could
consider single bars,
but they don't usually do much.
You're can just slide them
out parallel to themselves.
So there's a shift
in the indices
here, and that's why there's
a shift in the matrix.
Sounds ominous.
A shift in the matrix,
what will we do?
But they're basically the same.
So I'm going to show most
of these results to you.
The stars mean that even if
I give you-- get this right--
even if I give you a whole
bunch more hairpins-- so
for this result, it's
the most interesting.
I take a 3 chain, a 3 chain,
and then a millionaire hairpins,
a million 2 chains.
Still, they can separate.
And all the results
with stars, you
can add arbitrarily
many hairpins.
These two are the most
interesting, a 4 chain
with any number
of hairpins, a 2,
3 chain with any
number of hairpins.
These results do
not hold or we don't
know how to prove it anyway.
That's the summary.
There's one question that's
not answered by this table
because it's how low can
you go and get interlocking.
This is saying, well, once you
get to a 3 chain and a 4 chain,
you can interlock.
It's the minimum.
But what if you have a bunch
of 2 chains or even just one?
Can I interlock it with
some chain of some length?
Let's say, I mean up to
4 is the most interesting
because once you get to 5,
you can have knitting needles.
But suppose I take longer
open chains down here,
but I require that they're
not themselves locked.
Can I interlock
it with a hairpin?
It has practical
applications to hair I guess.
And the answer is yes.
So this first example
is a 16 chain.
That's the gray part.
Wow!
It's hard to even
follow the ends.
Here's one end.
And here's another end
and 16 bars in the middle.
And then the red
thing is a 2 chain,
and this is a model of
that thing, physical model.
And it's locked.
Sorry, it's interlocked,
I should say.
I'm pretty sure you take
either of the chains,
obviously with the
hairpin, but also
for the really
complicated 16 chain,
it will unfold by itself.
But with a hairpin, it is
held open at that angle
and can't unfold.
The best bound so far is an
11 chain versus a 2 chain.
It's conjectured to be optimal.
There's various
reasons to believe
at least this interlocking
trick where you-- basically,
all the hairpin can do is
hold an angle open or try to.
And this seems to be the
smallest way to interlock it
up there and the smallest way
to interlock it on either side.
And these are zooms.
This is of one of these corners.
This is of the top part.
So those, by
themselves, if you're
trying to do these
three interlock tricks,
these are minimal, we think.
But as an assembly, it's
conjectured to be optimal,
but we don't know
how to prove that.
But at least these
guys are interlocked,
so 11 chain with a 2 chain.
So those don't fit on the
table because the table's not
large enough.
But let me start
with this result.
So the easiest
thing to do is show
that if I have any finite
set of hairpins, 2 chains,
they never interlock.
This is actually an old
result although it was never
phrased this way until
earlier this decade,
I guess, by de Brujin, a famous
Dutch mathematician from 1954.
He proved essentially this.
He proved a simpler
version which was then
generalized in 1984 by
Robert Dawson in Canada.
And they proved
something more general.
They said, well-- I will say
a hairpin is star-shaped,
meaning if you were right here,
here's your eye at this point,
you can see the entire
interior of the shape
without leaving the shape.
So that's a star-shaped figure.
And these guys proved that
for star-shaped figures,
there's a way to
always separate them
without even changing
any of the angles.
There's no folding involved.
You could think
of rigid 2 chains.
They can all fly
apart from each other.
How do you do it?
Some fun geometry.
You say, I have my favorite
0, 0, 0 in three space.
I just want to scale
everything from the point,
make space bigger.
What will happen to
these poor little chains?
They get bigger.
They'll get longer.
As they get longer,
just cut them off again.
But the result is
that these points
will fly away from each other.
And so all of these two
chains are going to separate.
The lengths get longer, but I
can always cut them shorter.
And if I scale
space, obviously if I
didn't have
self-intersection before,
I still won't have
self-intersection.
So it's a fun motion.
We tried to draw it in the book.
It's a little hard to draw.
So we have the red, green,
and, blue-- hopefully,
you're not colorblind--
hairpins hanging out.
They're not hitting each other.
Here's the origin.
We scale everything, so the blue
guy goes to the dashed blue.
Green goes to the dashed green.
It looks weird.
It's all over the place.
And you're stretching
for this point,
so as you go farther
away, it's bigger.
Red guy expands to
the dashed red guy.
What's not shown here is
then you clip the red things.
Because everything
gets longer, you
can always clip to
the original lengths.
And that's a motion
of these chains.
You're not changing the angle.
Scaling preserves angles.
And everything flies
way for each other.
So a very nice trick
from a long time ago.
Once you get to 3 chains,
this doesn't work.
And so if we want to
prove this result, which
would subsume these guys, we
need to do a little more work.
Although a very
similar trick works.
So let me show you why two
open 3 chains separate.
Even if you add arbitrarily
many extra hairpins-- that's
the star-- Two 3
chains always separate.
I guess suppose we're
in a generic situation.
Nothing aligns that shouldn't.
I have one 3 chain, or
something like this.
And I have another one.
Let's make it interesting.
Is that possible?
Maybe.
Something like that.
Probably you want these
guys to be pretty long.
Do some crazy whatever.
That is two 3 chains
if I drew it right.
And the claim is you can
always separate them.
So here's the deal.
I have this middle bar.
There's a whole family of planes
that are parallel to that bar,
in fact, a lot of planes.
There's what?
Three dimensions of planes.
There's a two dimensional
family of planes
that are parallel to that bar.
There's a two dimensional family
of planes that are parallel
to that bar, meaning
if you extend it,
it doesn't hit the plane
or lies in the plane.
So there's actually a plane
that is parallel to both bars.
In fact, there's a whole
one dimensional family
of that, if I
figured it out right.
So you can actually find a
plane that bisects the two bars.
So there's one on one side,
one on the other side.
And even if the bars extended,
it would not hit the plane.
So there's some plane
in the middle here.
Really hard to draw in 3D.
Actually, I think
I have a picture.
It might be a little
easier to see.
So it looks something like this.
You have to believe me.
This is general case.
You have the red chain
and the blue chain.
The middle bars are on
opposite sides of the plane,
and they're parallel
to the plane.
Now what we do is
scale, but we only
scale in z, so
non-uniform scaling.
This will not preserve angles.
Here, we're going to fold.
So the result, we scale
from z equals zero,
so these guys get pushed down.
Those guys get pushed up.
Scaling in z, again, does not
cause any self-intersection.
And because we made
these guys parallel,
these edge lengths
will be preserved.
That's the key.
The end bars will
get longer, but I
don't care if they get longer.
I can always cut them shorter.
So that's the trick.
Yeah, they'll always
get longer, even
if they don't go
to the other side.
So that's how you can
just pull them apart.
And also, if there
are 2 chains in here,
they will also just fly
away from each other.
So eventually,
everything will get
far away unless they happen
to have the same z-coordinate,
but then it's degenerate.
Just perturbed a little bit.
Jason?
AUDIENCE: Is this the
case where the two
bars are coplanar and parallel?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I said at the beginning
generic, so in particular,
I want to assume that these
guys are not coplanar,
otherwise, you could just
perturb it a little bit.
As long as they're not touching,
you can wiggle everybody.
Good point.
That's two 3 chains.
There's one more result
in the separability.
We've done all of these
separability results here.
The next one would be this,
which is the same as this.
So here we have a 4
chain versus a 2 chain.
Basically, the same trick works.
I just have reorient to put
middle bars in the xy plane.
So in other words,
there's two middle bars.
They live in a plane
because they share a vertex.
So think of that as the plane
and then scale perpendicular
to the that.
Same trick works.
So 4 chains versus
various 2 chains.
Again, we preserve the
lengths of the two middle bars
because they lie on the plane.
So there's no scaling
that happens in the plane,
and in the generic
case, everybody
will be off the
plane, and they fly.
Cool.
So that proves all of
these separability results.
I'm not going to do these
closed chain ones here.
You can read the paper
if you're interested.
At this point, we can go
back to Lubiw's problem
and prove this result.
So basic algorithm is
cut every other vertex.
You'll get a whole
bunch of hairpins.
Hairpins, we know, separate.
But we can be slightly
more efficient
by leaving an initial segment
of 4 chain or two 3 chains.
I think it comes out
to the same number.
And you end up saving three
if we computed this right.
So you get n minus 3 over 2.
I think our first bound on this
problem was n minus 1 over 2,
and then we improved by 1
although I have to n minus 3
over 2.
That has stood the
best bound since.
Basically, because with
interlocked stuff-- after that,
you get interlocked.
And if you're going
to avoid interlocking,
you have to be clever.
You can't just use the numbers.
So that is all we know
about Lubiw's problem.
Now, I get to show you all
the fun interlocked examples.
We're going to do pretty
much all of these.
So we start with one of
the prettiest examples,
the threefold symmetric.
This is three 3 chains.
So that's not even drawn here.
Because this table is about
pairwise interactions.
We know that two 3 chains-- we
just proved two 3 chains cannot
interlock, but
three of them can.
That's the only case where
that question is interesting.
So everybody else,
you can interlock.
Unless you have 2 chains,
and we know those don't help.
So three 3 chains interlock.
I'm not going to try
to prove that here.
It's a pretty
complicated argument
where you look at
the center edges.
You look at the convex
whole of those edges
and argue these guys can't
stick into the center.
It's a geometric argument.
If you're interested,
check out this paper.
It's a pretty cool example.
This was a great-- finally,
I had a good exercise
for using Rhino yesterday
and drawing this figure.
It was a lot of fun.
This is a 3 chain and 4 chain.
One, two, three, four.
Just two different
views of the same thing.
And that proves this result,
which is this result.
It's pretty close, pretty tight.
Again, it's a
geometric argument.
It's tricky.
I'll go into it here.
We found these by building
lots of straw models
and jiggling them
around with string
connecting the straws together.
But then we had to prove it.
For a while, we weren't
sure whether a 3 and a 4
could interlock.
I think first we had a 4
and a 4 or maybe 4 and a 5,
and we kept working
our way down.
And now we know this is
the smallest you can get.
And now we go into
the closed results.
Because 4 and 4, that's of
course easier than 3 and 4.
So that's done.
This is contained
in those results.
Now, we look at the
closed examples.
So this is going to be a
closed triangle interlocking
with an open 4 chain.
And here I'm going to give
you some of the details
because this proof-- it's
relatively easy to prove
that this is interlock.
You can use a more
topological argument,
which is what we're used to
from the knitting needles.
Remember we took a ball that
separated the interior vertices
from the endpoints.
We said the endpoints
really can't get in
if we set the ball right.
And therefore, you could connect
the endpoints by a big rope,
and then you have
an Trefoil knot,
and there's no way you can
untie the knot with that
having intersection somewhere.
You can argue the rope
never self intersects,
so it must be the chain.
We can do the same
thing with this example,
with a 4 chain interlocked
with a triangle.
And we'll sketch that proof.
So I want to prove that those
two guys are interlocked,
so suppose that somehow they
separate from each other.
If there's a separating
motion, there's
a motion where the triangle
actually doesn't move at all.
So triangle's rigid,
except that it
can move by rigid motion,
translation and rotation.
But any motion I have, I can
recenter things by relativity
so that the
triangles stays fixed
and just the
quadrilateral moves.
So that's nice because a
triangle is a natural thing
to draw a sphere
around, and I want
to argue if these bars
are really, really long,
the endpoints will be
outside this big sphere.
So let me tell you how long.
I have my triangle
I'm going to draw
a sphere that
contains the triangle.
Say this sphere has
radius little r.
Big R is going to be
little r plus the sum
of the middle bars, which
should sound familiar from what
we did with knitting needles.
This is of the 4 chain.
There's two middle bars.
Add up their lengths.
Add on r.
This is just a big
number, capital R.
I'm going to make it bigger.
So I have my little triangle.
It has a tiny ball around it.
I'm going to draw a
pretty big sphere here
of radius 15 r, an even
bigger sphere of radius 20 r.
And I don't need to be precise
about exactly where the center
is, but I guess it would
be the center of this ball.
Here's what I want to say.
I'm supposing the lengths of
these edges is more than 20 r.
So initially, those
bars go outside the box.
The endpoints are
outside of the big ball.
Now, here's the claim.
As long as the endpoints of
the really long-- the endpoints
of the 4 chain stay outside this
ball, then the interior bars--
these two middle bars-- have
to stay inside this ball.
This is just like
the knitting needles.
As long as the super
long bars, the endpoints,
stay outside this
ball, the middle bars
have to stay inside.
That's just because those
bars are so darn long.
And so for as long
as that holds,
you can compute the
topology-- I'm not
going to try to draw it-- the
topology of-- in this picture,
if you connect to the
ends of the purple guys,
because they're outside the
big ball, the 15 r ball--
not sure I really
need the 20 r ball,
but the 15 r ball is the key--
topology you get is this.
That is the link
between the circle,
which is this nice loop.
And the purple guy
is that red loop
if you just figure out what
it looks like currently.
And as long as the endpoints
of these guys don't go inside
and those guys
remain on the inside,
basically until something
interesting happens,
the topology has to be that.
So at some point-- sorry,
I said that slightly wrong.
As long as the middle
bars stay inside the ball
and the endpoint stay
outside the ball, a 15 r,
this will be the case.
They are not saying nothing
interesting happened.
So violation, the
only way to open
this thing could be an endpoint
goes inside or a middle bar
goes outside the ball.
Consider the moment
when that happens.
If a middle bar, one
in the middle vertices
is going to go outside
this 15 r radius ball,
then you know that
all of the middle bars
are far away from this
triangle because those edges
very small compared
to capital R.
So we're 15 away.
If you have one middle vertex
that's outside, all of them
are pretty close to outside.
They're all going to
be in some smaller ball
here-- outside
that smaller ball.
The alternative is that
one of the end-- that's
not a contradiction yet,
but we'll come back to it--
the alternative is that one
of the endpoints of the bars
goes inside this
radius 15 r ball.
When that happens, because
this bar is so long,
the other end of the bar will
actually be outside the sphere.
And so then, again,
all the middle guys
are outside the sphere.
So either way, you violate.
I assumed this
before, but now, I'm
saying if you try to
take these guys out
or if you try to
push this guy in,
the middle guys are
outside the ball already.
So consider a situation when
the middle edges are all outside
the ball of radius 15 r.
The only thing that could
penetrate some tiny sphere,
like this one of little r,
only parts of the 4 chain
that could penetrate
that are the long bars
because the middle
stuff is too far away.
The long bars are super long,
so they could conceivably
penetrate the triangle.
All we really care about
is piercing the center
of the triangle
because that's when
we get interesting topology.
We want to get this
topology, but sadly, you
could only get these topologies.
I guess luckily.
You can only get those
three topologies,
which don't match this one.
And so there's no way
to get continuously
from one of these to the other.
That's the argument.
Let me say a little
more which is
if neither of the two long
bars hit the triangle,
then you trivially get this.
You don't get any linking.
If one of them strikes a
triangle, you always get this.
If two of them
strike the triangle,
it's possible to
get this or this
depending on how you link it up.
And I'm not going
to prove it here,
but that's all you can get.
And so if you can't get
this one, you're in trouble.
There's no continuous
motion from this to those
without crossing.
So that's how it goes.
And this is an example of
a topological argument.
You can use the same
kind of argument
to prove this last
result, which is this one.
But now this is not necessarily
symmetric because one's closed,
one's open.
So this is a closed 4 chain
quadrilateral, in other words,
with an open 3 chain,
which can also lock.
And again, you can use
the topological arguments.
A little messy because now this
is like a tetrahedron instead
of a triangle, but the same
tricks work and topology,
luckily, doesn't match between
the inside and outside cases.
Cool.
So that is interlocking
and pretty much
the entirety of this table.
Now, there's a way to
generalize this table,
which is instead of saying,
oh, I have universal joints.
Everything's nice.
I start thinking
back to proteins
and say, well, what if
I had some fixed angles.
What if some of the chains
are fixed angles and others
are universal?
What if some of the
chains were ridge?
Because we know that rigid
hairpins can separate
without any folding whatsoever,
what if some of them are rigid
and some of them are fixed angle
and some of them are universal?
Well, we haven't done all of
those results, but most of them
for pairs, we have got
universal and rigid.
I mean a fixed angle 2
chain is a rigid 2 chain,
so there's only
two columns there.
Universal fixed angle rigid.
And here we only
get up to rigid.
Yeah, I'm not sure if it makes
a huge difference out there.
Again, this is not
a complete story.
There other results
that might fit in here.
How far down do those minuses go
if you don't have rigid parts?
But let's see.
The plus means
there's locked things.
The minus means they
always separate.
It's a little more concise.
And we've sorted
the rows and columns
so that you get nice--
conveniently you
get a nice diagonal pattern,
not perfect diagonal,
but it's at least monotone.
It makes sense that a
rigid-- obviously, rigid
is more fixed than
a fixed angle.
But it's not obvious
that a universal 4 chain
is going to lock more than
a fixed angle 3 chain,
but turns out that is the
case for these examples.
Now, you could consider
triples of them,
each with different properties.
Then, you get a three
dimensional table.
That gets a little messier.
Probably not a huge
number of results
are necessary along those lines.
Here, we just needed the 2
chains plus the three 3 chains
were interlocked.
So there's more work
to be done here,
but this was a lot of fun.
And if you want to
see the examples,
you should check out this paper.
This was basically
for fun and to see how
low could you go in
terms of number of edges
and various combinations
of different parts.
But it turns out this interlock
stuff does have applications.
I'm not going to
call them practical
because it's about
another theory result.
And its result, I mentioned.
If you have some 3
chain-- oh sorry.
Some three dimensional chain--
let's say universal joints--
and you have two
configurations, configuration a
and configuration
b, and you want
to know is there a
motion from configuration
a to configuration b.
This is PSPACE-complete,
result by a bunch of Berliners
from a few years ago.
And basically, what they
do is build a computer.
I don't have the gadgets
here to show you.
But they build a computer
with various moving parts
and what not.
To build the infrastructure
of that computer,
the rigid part doesn't move.
They use interlocked chains.
Basically, if you want to
build a nice, rigid framework,
like a truss, you can do it
because you just take chains.
I'm only allowed to make chains.
I'm not allowed to make graphs.
But if I bring two
parts of the chain
really close to each
other, I can basically
tie a knot by making
lots of little links
and using say an
interlocked 3, 4 chain,
interlock 3 chain with
an interlocked 4 chain.
In the same way
when we're building
the locked 11 chain
with the lock 2 chain,
you're tying little knots
around various points.
Here, we don't even
have to be efficient,
just constant numbers are fine.
So you can build some rigid
structure like a tetrahedron
by taking one path here,
making an interlock structure,
making interlock structure,
interlock, interlock.
Could double traverse, I guess.
And you can interlock
everything using a chain.
Build a rigid structure.
Then, you go and build
the flexible part.
And that's the fun computation.
But just to get off
the ground and to build
some rigid infrastructure,
to build gadgets basically
in your hardness proof,
they use interlocked chains,
which is pretty cool.
This is a really interesting
result, a very negative one.
It's really hard to fold
from one shape to another,
but it uses this.
They also prove the same thing
for trees in two dimensions.
For that, they used
the lock trees--
which we covered way
back, lecture three
or whatever-- these lock trees
to build-- to basically fill
rigid angles, to force things
to be at particular angles,
and then they have flexible
parts to do the computer stuff.
So it's fun.
They use our little examples
to build big computers.
Still open, of
course, is can I start
from a straight
configuration of the chain
and can I get it to this.
So in other words, given
a chain, can I unfold it.
We'd like to know whether
that's polynomially
solvable or empty complete.
It is about characterizing
lock chains in some sense.
This is about going
from arbitrary
configuration to
arbitrary configuration.
And here, you're
allowed to build
rigid infrastructure
which never moves.
Here, everything would
have to fall apart somehow,
so you can't use
interlock chains.
You can't use lock trees in 2D.
So this problem is still open.
Seems quite
difficult because you
can't build any infrastructure
the stays around forever.
Everything would
have to fall apart
if your machine terminates.
Any questions?
Wanted to talk about
that for a long time.
Now that we have
interlock chains,
you get to see a little bit
behind the scenes of what's
happening.
If you want to see
the full proof,
check out that paper by
[INAUDIBLE], [INAUDIBLE],
and [INAUDIBLE].
All right.
That's it.